this is donna brazile now you of course
know her as the democrat swamp creature
who got fired from CNN after she leaked
a debate question of the clinton camp
last year during the election CNN leaks
Clinton that's a hat trick of globalist
evil somebody throw an octopus on the
ice now she's been an institution of the
Democratic Party for decades advising
the Clintons serving twice as the
interim chairperson for the DNC and
painting on Bernie Sanders age spots
it's all a hoax he's actually 32 years
old she's an enemy and we freethinkers
have always known it
donna brazile internment resident which
in chief head of the DNC turns out Donna
Brazile also a big liar she just is
unbelievably arrogant and has the
deadest eyes I think I've ever seen
that's right
she has the deadest eyes he's ever seen
and you know Jones has seen a dead body
before so that's really saying something
bottom line she is our eternal enemy
until last week former DNC chief Donna
Brazile dropping the bomb on Democrats
Donna Brazile published an excerpt of
her new book accused the Clinton
campaign and the DNC of entering into in
her words an unethical fundraising
agreement before Clinton won the
nomination in exchange for helping the
deeply in debt DNC raise money staff
with Hillary for America would have
quote joint authority over strategic
decisions like staffing budget and
communications some Democrats say
point-blank the DNC rigged the election
do you agree with the notion that it was
rigged yes the Donna Brazile situation
Democrat party it is folks this is
amazing oh the Democrats have a donna
Brazile situation not to be confused
with the Johnny Brasil situation my nan
fixer thriller about a tall slender
rogue from Michigan who becomes the
sexiest spy in South America armed only
with a devastating glance and the power
of prayer
let me repeat the bombshell that not to
be dropped Hillary was bankrolling the
DNC and rigged the primary to keep
Bernie from winning the nomination yet
again a straight white man has been
victimized by systemic oppression guys
we are under attack Mumford and Sons
steamed chicken upside-down visors
voting rights better Donna is finally
using her evil powers for good so let me
be the first to say Donna Brazile
welcome to the team
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that's favorite kind of dancing just
like a metronome
anyone who says the Democrats into a
panic tailspin is fine by me and I know
you're on TV saying hey you're doing
this out of civic responsibility and
sunlight is the best disinfectant but
you and I know the real reason you gotta
sell that book scandals sell people love
gossip just like the ladies loved Johnny
Brazil on those main Main streets of Rio
and Donna's book packs a lot of sweet
heat calling Obama and Hillary Titanic
egos fear-mongering over Hillary's dizzy
spells and exposing Tim Kaine as just a
snowman that animates when a harmonica
plays I assume I'm only halfway through
but I know that's where it goes
Brazil is a natural on our team she's
already got an arsenal of talking points
and knows how to hit back at mainstream
haters that got some controversial
chapters I understand but anybody from
Louisiana Noda I'm gonna put some hot
sauce on every page and if it that if
it's not dripping with something that's
hot and spicy it's not me
I know street politics better I know
sweet politics for those who are telling
me to shut up they told Hillary that a
couple of months ago you know what I
tell them go to hell
whoa now that's how we have discourse at
our side shut up counterpoint you
Oh Donna your rage is music to my ears
that's why I made it music to my ears
play it
[Music]
oh man but another baby that would be
the lullaby I'd sing every night it's
got a beat and you can hate the Clintons
to it now
Donna is finally out in front exposing
crooked Hillary for her rigging ways and
I am on the rig train and she is the
conductor rigged rigged that's why like
I said she's with us and there's no
going back
I've even started DVR and all of her TV
appearances Chuck show me the one for
this morning you wrote in part I had
promised Bernie when I took the helm of
the Democratic National Committee after
the convention I'd get to the bottom of
whether Hillary Clinton's team had
rigged the nomination process by
September 7th I had found my proof and
it broke my heart you've said since that
you never said that the process was
rigged the process was not rigged what
back to hell you swamp creature I
trusted you